kann sich ja mal ein blatt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
herzlich kommt sondern folglich fahrer
leute heute machen wir ein ausflug in
den süden nach italien mit diesem wagen
ihr ferrari
488 geben
[Musik]
und unser heutiger gast ist max greger
direkt vorneweg leute ganz viele fragen
was ja immer wie kommen die leute an die
autos bei der marxisten wir sind ja auch
ganz offen und transparent der wagen
gehörte onkel von dir mitglied und du
fährst aber sehr oft damit und bis heute
damals zu gast leute deswegen seit den
kommentaren freundlich wir sind alle
sehr sehr happy dass wir diese autos zu
erleben dürfen jetzt laufen meine runde
rom kommt bzw stopp erst mal ja schonmal
kabul angriff ja also das ist noch ein
thema ist welt ihr noch häufiger sehen
bei diesem auto übrigens v8 falls ihr
euch fragt woher der name 488 kommt der
kommt vom hubraum ist ein zehnzylinder
dass der ist ein v8 wie gesagt turbo
biturbo der 3,9 0 2 liter hubraum einig
wenn man das durch acht teilt weil
achtzylinder kommt man auf 487 75 aud
das franchise namen ferrari 487 75 kauft
keiner dass wir haben ein bisschen
aufgerundet 488 oa dr huhu carbon
keramik sieht man hier an der musterung
geil ich diese bremsanlage ist eine
richtig geile farbe auch dass es greco
förderung also eisen grau quasi völlig
geil müsst euch mal gehen wollte mit den
gelben akzenten
japan fängt dieses emblem hier kostet
ein fach mal 15 aufpreis der ganze wagen
230 basis beziehungsweise
war das ja aber kommen warum kommt warum
leute wir schauen direkt manhattan in
den motorraum rein gottseidank hast du
den gtb hier und ich bin zweiter also
ich das cabrio weil beim cabrio hast du
hinten noch eine kleine klappe und der
motor stottert versteck hier beim btb
und gut siehst du noch alles durch diese
scheibe das machen wir eben auch
leute guckt man diesen carbon angriff an
das ist wirklich alter die rückkehr der
carbon krieger hier
dieses rot hier carbon
ist das sexy alter und ich habe noch
keine kommentare 488 oder zwei endrohre
458 hat drei hier in der mitte was find
ich geiler ventilen und
nebelschlussleuchte stattdessen sieht
auch geil aus wir müssen einzig aus
liebe vorbereitet ja
ja richtig geil ich finde zwei endrohre
boss will ja 450 schon gefahren f8
tributo gefahren quasi den jüngeren und
den nachfolger und das hier ist jetzt
wer in der mitte liga das ist einfach
aggro hier auch carbon
also merker bund gibt es nicht denn egal
da muss das auto komplett aus karbon ja
das ist so geil hinten 310 waschlappen
305 er glaube
dass das für
gewalt sind sind narnia killer
heckdiffusor kabul egal
wie man 60 newtonmetern noch fragen drei
sekunden null auf hundert noch
irgendwelche fragen ich glaube nicht
hier so sexy alter wie der ferrari star
ganz wenige knöpfe ganz viel am lenkrad
das maritimo hier
das ist einfach so fucking sex sieht die
schaltanzeige hier online
man muss alles richtig race richtiger
wunsch einwirken und diese schaltanzeige
und kommst glaube ich auch in
dreieinhalb auf lenkrad alleine küche
schon
25.000 oder das
maskottchen kann diese auch niemals
fahren bei dem wir gerade lenker oder
geklaut ist das
ist dass kinder hier haben auch carbon
warum leute lufteinlass carbon und ihr
bei ferrari ist nix schau das hat alles
funktionen jede jeder lufteinlass jede
ein formung hier hat eine aerodynamik
funktion gerade bei 488 hat auch ganz
viel über den unterboden von der
aerodynamik das ist alles mit funktionen
hat ist nicht wie bei audi die ich ja
eigentlich sehr mag mit den fake blenden
und so dass nicht schon hier ist alles
ruhig und sehr real ist auch das wäre ja
kein italienisches auto wenn sich so
wäre die verbraucher durchschlagen der
ist glaube ich in der gleichen art weiß
auch bei sehr vielen anderen 14
das ist auch noch sagen der wagen hat
als herauskam richtig die gesagt man die
gemüter gespalten weil der 48 40 vorwand
sauger der hat jetzt ein biturbo hinten
drin zwei turbolader mit jeweils fünf
euro aufladung und das ist nicht immer
so ein ding wenn vorher sauger ist und
dann die tour bus kommen sind die
aussicht ist also mein gott die welt
geht unter aber
bisher haben schon her gefahren erklingt
bombe ja ist überhaupt erst nach dem
california at glaube ich der zweite
ferrari es seit 92 42 und dann der kfw
und dann der 488 quasi nervigen
emissions- und so weiter und so fort
machen soundcheck
[Gelächter]
egal
der klingt ja so racing aussage wenn es
um 488 geht weil das gras
naja
egal das ist ja richtig geil hoch völlig
boah krass in unterschiedlichen v8
klingen kann naja hamburg link kenne ja
also lange bevor 10 halt meist oder vor
zwölf aber jetzt in einem v8 oder so und
ich weiß hier gleich aus sozusagen war
besser und damit sitzen wir eben 488 gtw
leute let's go das licht hält uns davon
müssen schnell machen das hier bin ich
direkt von vorne und
[Musik]
alles klar dann packt
huhu huhu
netzwerks ich darf meine stadt fahren
gar nicht vergessen vor lauter aufregung
was bedeutet es für dich es war für mich
immer ein bestandteil schon von kleinen
und ich sag mal so
die für mich nicht nur ein
fortbewegungsmittel von a nach b sondern
einfach auf mehr als ein hobby für mich
definitiv
die möglichkeit hat sich autos zu fahren
geht da ich glaube ich dem auto zehn
reiter also ich bin da bisher da noch
dankbar dafür ich bin das thema glaube
ich mit 18 das auto gefahrenen mona saß
und jetzt war ich damals noch gibt es in
vegas alter und man muss auch dazu sagen
leute im auge machen ist auch ungesund
ich glaube wenn wir das kann ich
zumindest sagen wir nicht ein onkel
hätte der sagt er ist 1 488 phase würde
ich sagen alter sofort unterschreiben
deswegen muss auch gönnen leute gilt
hierfür können und fdp ferrari gefahren
dass der stadtschlüssel haltern da kommt
ein beispiel für ein gerät ist so sexy
alter und wenn man ferrari fährt habe
ich schon gesehen also hinter ihm her
gefallen ist gerade eben die leute in
seiner normalen autos krieger auf einmal
so richtig versteht mich nicht falsch
aber
andere leute kriegen dann einfach mal
zwang sich zu beweisen und hu weinandy
warten wird's grün erste millisekunde
bahn bis ein ruft er sofort ich kann mir
glaube ich auch jünger aussieht als was
ich schon ich denke also
stinkefinger möglich kassier tag auf der
straße und bis heute auch wieder böse
kommentare ich bin nur an der seite
gestanden kann auch jemand vorbei und
einfach
ruhig
tschuldigung ich habe doch gar nichts
gemacht
doch einfach da es gibt auch viele leute
die können und ist das finde ich mich
aber ich habe es gehört schon gesehen
das verstehe ich auch nicht man muss
jetzt ja nicht gemein zu leuten sein
weil du weißt doch am ende auch wurscht
ob das was man für 2000 euro kostet so
viel wie ein ferrari das ist es auch
kein anderer mensch davon leben aber
naja kann sich auch mal zu du kannst
kommt
[Musik]
die schaltpunkte zu müssen
also wenn du erfahren hast ein auto klar
aber das ist ja unfassbar und ja
[Musik]
ist das ein schub alter das ist ja nicht
normal
das ist ja absolut illegal liga
alter vater
[Musik]
das ganz gerne und her
leidenschaft
[Musik]
der geist das krank aber der fällt oft
sogar auf race ist der absoluten nicht
brechen oder irgendwas das finde ich ist
es gerade mittelmotor sportwagen
[Musik]
dass es so aggressiv ticker ihr macht
euch kein bild leute
ja das ist so kranken aggressiv und man
schaut nach hause bioware fach tribute
und du siehst die ausgestellten
kotflügel
sie kommen nicht genug
die wollen wieder um die kurve geht
junge schlussmann durch die stadt
wow ist das krank
absolut geisteskrank klar ist auch der
hat so viel power und so ein geiles
handling und auch sophie traktion
den kann es auf der straße unmöglich
auch nur annähernd aus fragen geht nicht
deswegen können wir heute auch nur in
kleinen eindruck davon gewinnen leute
einfach unfassbar und
der klingt viel besser als erwartet wenn
ich mich recht erinnere ich glaube ich
finde schon bei 11 80 schneider dann
wahrscheinlich mehr väter in der scheiße
gefühlt
was wird auch zu sagen kannst du eine
faust geben ich kenne den verschiedenen
killer diese kleine kostprobe aus
italien
affengeil jetzt ab in die bewertung wird
die bewertung beginnt immer mit dem aus
dem leute und ich finde da es heute zeit
für eine premiere guillon ferro mit
diesen gelben elementen und dem ganzen
carbon finde ich einfach so geil dass
ich hier zum ersten mal 10 von 10
punkten fürs aussehen geben will
schreibt mir keine kommentare was der
inhalt und die beschleunigung ist
absolut geisteskrank das kann man
wirklich nicht anders sagen aber liegt
eben nicht unter der magischen grenze
von 30 und 500 deswegen gibt's hier neun
von zehn und bei der coolness gibt es
überhaupt keine zwei meinungen zumindest
in meinen augen da muss es eine 10 von
10 geben das ding ist einfach affengeil
in der spaß wäre damit 29 von 30 punkten
und einen geteilten ersten platz
zusammen mit dem f 8 reboot und dem ura
kam von imax kein praktikabilität ist
natürlich ferrari typisch nicht ganz so
gut da gibt es keinen grund mehr punkte
zu geben als mann mehrfach tribute oder
aber im 458 dementsprechend drei von
zehn preis leistung wieder schwierig
230.000 basis dafür aber auch sieben
jahre kostenlose wartungen bei ferrari
unter dem strich ein auto was wir besser
gefallen als der f8 tributo einfach weil
der 488 noch ein bisschen mehr emotionen
transportiert er hat noch mehr sound
klar ist auch ein älteres auto
dementsprechend nicht so hart reguliert
auch wenn er fast 50 ps mehr hat und
noch mal ein bisschen mehr schiebt er
den finde ich gerne 1 488 ist aufgrund
des geistes kann preises aber kann ich
ja nicht mehr erst mit von 10 geben
zuletzt der komfort ist wirklich
wirklich überraschend gut selbst auf
race ist das auto längst nicht bockhardt
oder irgendwas hat mir sehr sehr positiv
überrascht aber fünf von zehn werden
auch zu viel weil das auto ist nicht so
komfortabel wie 9/11 war oder wie ein z
44 das ist einfach so vier von zehn es
angebracht damit in der alltagswelt
legendäre 12 von 30 und platz 17 von den
autos aber ganz ehrlich das juckt auch
in 488 nicht in der gesamtwertung aber
gibt es 41 von 60 punkten was richtig
richtig starkes für sohn radikalen
sportwagen als ich bin echt sehr sehr
positiv überrascht uns persönlich finde
böse überrascht war geisteskrank
geflasht von diesem auto das hat mich
komplett weg geflasht einfach affengeil
auf jeden fall fehlen dafür zuschauer
leute und bis zum nächsten sonntag macht